former deputy assistant to the president
Fox News national security strategist
talked to Sebastian Gorka and retired
CIA senior intelligence officer Fox News
contributor Danielle Hoffmann proud to
announce that both of them will be with
this program in Singapore Sarah Carter
will be there as well as of course the
IG report two days after the Singapore
summit a lot of ground to cover tonight
let's start with you Daniel Hoffman and
the president showing strength I'll walk
away any time it's right out of the art
of the deal doesn't surprise me and I
believe and know him well enough to know
he absolutely would walk away in four
seconds yeah and I think he's also doing
the right thing by managing expectations
he's dealing with decades of failed
policy from which we've learned a lot
you know that we've talked a lot about
the sunshine policy that was more like
moonshine policy for North Korea at the
end of that 10-year period
they'd taken three billion dollars from
South Korea and oboes two billion
dollars from China increased their
nuclear programs significantly and we
hadn't denuclearized them taking really
many steps to denuclearize the peninsula
the Presidents taken on board all of
those lessons learned from the past and
I think he's really well prepared to go
forward with a really bold strategy for
dealing with with this challenge that we
face I think the challenge will be
dealing with some of the other countries
from the six-party talks like Russia and
China who are meddling and not always
helpful certainly on the part of Russia
to solving the crisis you know something
the world would be a lot better off if
we don't have Kim jong-un and the Korean
Peninsula threatened by North Korea and
ending the Korean War
dr. Gorka seems to me to be a pretty
good idea and would be good for the
world and that we have confirmed that
Kim jong-il will talk about complete
denuclearization of the of his regime
good for the world after 65 years
absolutely just just the absurdity that
this war is still really according to
the lack of a peace treaty in effect
it's just a ceasefire so yeah let's do
it let's go there let
denuclearize the peninsula this isn't
some dictatorship that's going to fall
tomorrow we're not going to solve all of
the peninsula's problems but if anybody
can end the war if anybody can demonize
it its president Trump agreed does it
concern you that it reporters notes
sources and everything the DOJ is
obtained dr. korkor instinctively this
sounds really bad to me yeah I don't
care whether the president's a
Republican or Democrat oh who the
reporter works for that amount of
information being demanded and captured
by the DOJ on what basis on what basis
Barr is very high as we know all right I
will get to be with you both in North
Korea I'm suffering for it under that
the North Korea summit with Donald Trump
in Singapore on Monday in Singapore all
right guys